say i've got some matrix a it's an n by
k
matrix let's say it's not just any n by
k matrix this matrix a
has a bunch of columns that are all
linearly independent so a1 a2
all the way through ak are linearly
independent
they are linearly independent columns
let me write that down here so a1
a2
all the column vectors of a
all the way through a k
are
linearly independent now what does that
mean that means that the only solution
to x1 times a1 plus x2 times a2
that's a 1 plus all the way to xk
times ak
but the only solution to this is all of
these x's have to be 0.
so all
x i's
must be equal to 0. that's what linear
independence implies or another way to
write it is
all the solutions to this equation
to this equation x1 x2
all the way down
xk equaling the zero vector that all of
the solutions to this are all of these
entries have to be equal to zero this is
just another way of writing this right
there we've seen it multiple times
that's the zero vector right there so if
all of these have to be 0 that's like
saying that the only solution
only solution
to
ax is equal to 0
is
x is equal to the zero vector or another
way to say it this is all coming out of
the fact that this guy's columns are
linearly independent
so linear independence of columns
of columns
based on that we can say since the only
solution to ax is equal to zero is x is
equal to the zero vector we know that
the null space
of a must be equal to the zero vector or
it's a set with just the zero vector in
it and that is all a bit of review now n
by k we don't know its dimensions it may
or may not be a square matrix so we
don't know necessarily whether it's
invertible and all of that
but maybe we can construct an invertible
matrix with it so if we take eight let's
study a transpose times a
a transpose
times a
a is an n by k matrix
a transpose will be a k by n matrix
so a transpose a is going to be a k by k
matrix so it's a square matrix so that's
a that's a nice that's a nice
place to start for an invertible matrix
so let's see if it is actually
invertible we don't know anything about
a all we know is its columns are
linearly independent let's see if a
transpose a is invertible
invertible
invertible and essentially to show that
it's invertible if we could show that
all of its columns are linearly
independent then we'll know it's
invertible if we have any and i'll get
back this back to this at the end of the
video but if you have a square matrix
if you have a square matrix
matrix
matrix with
linearly independent columns
remember the linear in the linearly
independent columns all
all uh are associated with pivot columns
when you put them in reduced row echelon
form so if you have a square matrix then
you're going to have exactly so if it's
a k by k matrix that means you're going
to have k
that means that the reduced row echelon
form
of matrix
will
have k pivot columns
have k pivot columns
pivot columns
and b and k by k and be a square k by k
matrix and there's only one k by k
matrix with k pivot columns and that's
the identity matrix and that is the
identity matrix the k by k identity
matrix and if when you reduce something
to reduced row echelon form and you get
the identity matrix that means that your
matrix is invertible
that means it's invertible
i could have probably left that to the
end of the video but i just want to show
you if we can show that we already know
that this guy is square that a transpose
a is a square matrix if we can show that
given that a has linearly independent
columns that a transposed times a also
has linearly independent columns then
given that the columns are linearly
dependent and it's a square matrix that
tells us that when we put into reduced
row echelon form we'll get the identity
matrix and that tells us that this thing
would be invertible so let's see if we
can prove that all of these this guy's
columns are linearly independent
so let's say i have some
vector
v
let's say my vector v
is a member of the null space
is a member of the null space of a
transpose a
that
means
that if i take a transpose a
times my vector v
i'm going to get the zero vector
fair enough
now what happens if i multiply both
sides of the equation times the
transpose of this guy
so i'll get v transpose actually let me
just do it right here if i multiply v
transpose on this side and v transpose
on this side and this is you could view
this as a as a matrix vector product
right or in general when you take a you
know if you think if if you take a a row
vector times a co
times a column vector it's essentially
their dot product so this right hand
side of the equation you dot anything
with the zero vector this is just going
to be
that is just going to be the zero vector
now what is the left hand side of this
going to be
we've seen this before
if you have the transpose of
we could view this as even though it's a
transpose of a vector you could view it
as a
it is a row vector but you could also
view it as a matrix
right a column vector is a you know
let's say v is a member v is a k by 1 is
a k by 1 matrix v transpose would be a 1
by k matrix anyway we've seen this
before that that is equal to the reverse
product
the transpose of the reverse product or
if we take the product of two things and
transpose it that's the same thing as
saying the reverse
product of the transposes of either of
those two matrices so given that we can
replace this right here with
a times the vector v transpose and we're
taking we're multiplying this vector
we're multiplying this vector times
a v
times this vector right here and that
that is going to be equal to the zero
vector now
what is this if i'm taking some vectors
transpose and let's say you know this is
a vector remember this is you know even
though i have a matrix vector product
right here when i multiply a matrix
times this vector may will result in
another vector so this is a vector and
this is a vector right here and if i
take some vector
and i multiply its transpose times that
vector we've seen this before that is
the same thing as y
dot y these two statements are identical
so this thing right here is the same
thing as
av
av
dot
av
this is the same thing as av dot av
and so what does the right hand side
equal the right hand side is going to be
equal to zero actually let me just make
a correction up here when i take v
transpose times the zero vector
v transpose is going to have k elements
and then the zero vector is also going
to have k elements and when i take this
product that's like dotting it you're
taking the dot product of v and zero so
this is the dot product of v with the
zero vector which is equal to zero the
scalar zero so this right here is the
scalar zero i wanna make sure i
clarified that it wouldn't have made
sense otherwise so the right hand side
when i multiply the zero vector times
the transpose of d it gets just the
number zero no vector zero there so this
av dot av is going to be equal to zero
or we could say that the
magnitude
the magnitude of
a or the length of av squared is equal
to zero
or that tells us that av has to be equal
to zero the only vector whose length is
zero is the zero vector
so av let me switch colors i'm using
that a little bit too much
so we know
that a
v
must be equal to zero to the zero vector
right this must be equal to the zero
vector since its length is zero
now we started off with saying v is a
member of the null space is a member of
the null space of a transpose a v could
be any member of the null space
any member of the null space of a
transpose a but then we were but then
from that assumption it turns out that v
also has to be a member
of the null space of a that av is equal
to 0.
so let's write that down if
v is a member of the null space of a
transpose a then
then v
is a member of the null space of a
now our null space of a because a's
columns are linearly independent it only
contains one vector it only contains the
zero vector
so
if this guy is a member of the null
space of a transpose a and he has to
remember a member of the null space of a
there's only one thing he can be there's
only one entry there so then v
v
has to be equal to
the zero vector or another way to say
that is any v that's in our in the null
space of a transpose a has to be the
zero vector
or
the null space
of a transpose a is equal to the null
space of a
which is equal to
just the zero vector sitting there now
what does that do for us
that tells us that the only solution
the only solution to
a transpose a
times
times some vector x equal to 0 this says
that the only solution
only solution
solution
is the zero vector is let me write
is x is equal to the zero vector right
because the null space of a transpose a
is the same as the null space of a and
that just has the zero vector in it the
null space is just the solutions to this
so if the only solutions to the null
space is this that means that the
columns of a
that means that the columns
of a transpose a
are linearly independent you could
essentially write the
all of the linear combinations of the
columns by the weights of the entries of
x we actually did that at the beginning
it's the same argument we used up here
so if all of their columns are linearly
independent and i said it over here a
transpose a has linearly independent
columns and it's a square matrix and
it's a square matrix that was kind of
from the definition of it so that we now
know that a transpose a a transpose a if
i were to put it let me do it this way
that tells me that the reduced row
echelon form of a transpose a
is going to be equal to the identity the
k by k identity matrix which tells me
that a transpose a
is invertible
invertible which is a pretty neat result
i started with a matrix
that has linearly independent columns so
it wasn't just any matrix
it wasn't just any run-of-the-mill
matrix it did have linearly independent
columns but it might have weird
dimensions it's not necessarily a
squared square matrix but i could
construct a square matrix a transpose a
with it and we now know that it also has
linearly independent columns it's a
square matrix and therefore it is
invertible